buenos días muchas gracias
no sé si son las más importantes de la
historia democrática pero son
verdaderamente elecciones muy
importantes por el contexto en el que
estamos arribando a este proceso
electoral
es han creado mucha expectativa mucha
aprensión
la violencia que hemos vivido el año
pasado después del proceso electoral y
que se de alguna manera se nos ha
mantenido en un estado de detención de
conflicto de roce entonces nos jugamos
lo mismo que nos jugamos todas las
elecciones el futuro legítimo del futuro
de un gobierno legítimamente constituido
que nos ayude a superar las dificultades
que estamos enfrentando no solamente
específicamente en bolivia sino en todo
el mundo por las consecuencias
económicas sociales de la emergencia
sanitaria la emergencia ambiental que
estamos viviendo y lo que se lo que se
añade digamos a lo que está en juego
es acercarnos a nuestro compromiso y a
nuestra vocación democrática y lograr
una transferencia acidificado de la
gestión del hogar y se logrará esto
doctora shuar se lograran estas
elecciones poner fin a esas turbulencias
institucionales que nos están
identificando como sería la
gobernabilidad nos quedan dos minutos un
minutito por cada respuesta de favor
mire no no no sé no podría asegurarle
nada creo que esta es exactamente la
pregunta que todos nos hacemos estamos
confiando en la institucionalidad la
transparencia y la probidad de los
resultados electorales para lograrlo y
también estamos contando con el
compromiso expresado por los candidatos
y sus partidos para que esto sea así
pero no puedo negar que hay nervios hay
expectativas hay hay tensión en el
ambiente
qué pasa si gana luízar se doctora del
más cuál sería el futuro de evo morales
que hoy está en argentina nos quedan 40
segundos
bueno si gana en la primera vuelta
tenemos que ir todavía a la segunda
vuelta dependiendo de la diferencia que
tenga hasta ahora la tendencia que
muestran las elecciones que vamos a
tener todavía una segunda vuelta y vamos
a tener tela para cortar entonces no
sabemos todavía qué va a pasar con eso
muy bien vivían su arts blue muchas
gracias por esta comunicación y su
análisis
ella es socióloga y doctora en ciencia
política